the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for our first official look at Game
of Thrones Season eight that's right
folks we now have some actual footage
and dialogue from the final season a
game of Thrones I don't know if you've
been following me on Twitter or not but
I had a very good feeling that HBO would
drop some footage this weekend simply
because these things tend to happen
whenever I'm not at home I'm actually in
North Carolina at the moment visiting
one of my close friends and I just so
happened to look at my phone and see a
notification from HBO's YouTube channel
and sure enough what do you know HBO
dropped another teaser for Game of
Thrones so I had to drop everything and
rush back to my hotel room so I could
get my initial thoughts out to you as
soon as possible
luckily I did have the foresight to
bring all my recording equipment with me
because like I said I did have a really
good feeling that something like this
would happen this weekend but anyways
let's get into the short teaser from HBO
it definitely looks like the teaser
confirmed who songs that may have been
looking at when they released the short
clip of Jon & Sons a hug in a few months
ago that's right ladies and gentlemen
Songza was looking at Daenerys Targaryen
and I do have to say these ladies are
looking gorgeous good lord
but let me stay on track here before we
go any further why don't we take a look
at the clip that we can talk about what
is happening in that scene
when fellas you love your grace when
fellas your grace so as you can see in
the short video clip John and Daenerys
have arrived in Winterfell to prepare
for the upcoming war against the night
king in this scene Jon and Sons are
already standing next to each other as
Daenerys and Jorah Mormont begin to
approach Sansa I would say that this is
expected because Jon of course would
want to hug Sansa first before he starts
to introduce her to all these other
characters that he has brought with him
after Psalms and Daenerys do greet each
other we here Sansa say Winterfell is
yours your grace now some of you may be
wondering why would son just say
something like that but you have to
remember jon is technically no longer
the king in the north because he did
bend the knee to Daenerys Targaryen John
has recognized her as the true queen of
the Seven Kingdoms therefore Winterfell
is Danny's now if you remember back in
the first season Ned Stark said the
exact same thing to rob a Baratheon nine
years I am not seeing you where the hell
have you been guarding the north for you
your grace
Winterfell is yours so as of right now
Jon would technically be the warden of
the north
just like Ned Stark was however I
believe that Sansa will remain as the
lady of Winterfell while Jon spends most
of his time commanding the troops well
that is until John finds out who he
truly is which we all know John is the
true heir of the iron throne and not
Daenerys but we will cross that bridge
at a later time it does look like Psalms
and Daenerys could actually get along
with each other and I think that without
Littlefinger being around to influence
or manipulate Sansa she might actually
put aside any differences she may have
with Daenerys for the greater good of
the realm with the night King heading
their way they really don't have time
for any unnecessary fighting amongst
each other however this is Game of
Thrones after all what are the chances
that all of these characters get along
with each other during the downtime it's
probably not very likely especially when
we know that Jaime Lannister is on his
way there as well things should start to
really get interesting when he arrives
in the north
but another thing that I do want to
point out is who Daenerys was with when
she greeted sawn zone Daenerys was
standing next to Sir Jorah Mormont who
we all know is related to literally on a
Mormont
one of John's most loyal supporters I
don't know about you but I'm very
interested in seeing Jorah and Lyanna
Mormont interact with each other I do
imagine that lianna will has some harsh
words for Jorah when you consider he
embarrassed their entire family by his
actions I fought beside them once long
ago now Ned stop once my head he drove
me from my land you sold slaves I
why no money an expensive wife but I
also imagine that he will be forgiven
when she learns that Jorah also
volunteered to go out beyond the wall
with Jon Snow
we all know that Jorah has made some
mistakes but he has already been
forgiven by Jon and Daenerys now I'm
also anxious to see how Daenerys and
Arya Stark get along with one another I
know that some people thought Arya and
Daenerys could bump heads because of
Danny's relationship with John but Arya
might actually get along with Daenerys
more than Sansa does if you remember
when Arya was time when Lannister's
cupbearer she revealed that she took
interest in the history of the Targaryen
s' more specifically the female members
of House Targaryen señor Vega I'm sure I
knew that when I was a boy you're saying
a Targaryen was a great warrior had a
Valyrian steel sword she called dark
sister
she's a heroine of you was gonna take it
when Aria sees Daenerys takin those
dragons into battle I imagine she will
have an enormous amount of respect for
her but only time will tell I just know
that is another meeting that I am
interested in getting to see next season
but we all know which reunion Trump's
all of them in my opinion that is the
reunion between John and Arya
all the best swords have names you know
sounds it can keep her sewing needles
I've got a needle of my own
now we don't get any signs of this and
the short clip HBO just released but I
guarantee Arya is standing just out of
frame in that scene if you watched my
episode 1 breakdown video I just
released a few days ago then you would
know how crazy this scene is about to be
there will be reunion after reunion
during this initial opening scene at
Winterfell now we all know we're gonna
see Sansa and Jon reunite of course but
we will also see Jon and Arya reunite
Jon and bran reunite and some other
characters that we have all been dying
to see characters like Tyrion and Sansa
Sandor Clegane and Arya Stark and
gangjae and Arya Stark this should make
for one hell of an opening scene which I
know I cannot wait to see in just a few
short months make sure that you keep
your eyes peeled ladies and gentlemen
because we will be getting a full
trailer very very soon
but anyways I don't want to ramble on
too long because this was only like a
five-second scene that HBO released but
as I said once that official trailer
drops I will overanalyze the [ __ ] out of
every single frame they release until
then make sure you watch my episode
breakdown videos I have been releasing
as of lately I'm currently working on
the 3rd episode as we speak and as you
all know the 3rd episode of season 8
will be one of the greatest episodes in
television history
stay tuned to my friends because more
Game of Thrones is right around the
corner I want to thank everyone for
watching this video about my initial
thoughts of the teaser and I also want
to thank everyone for supporting my
channel during the off season I really
do appreciate that I hope you all have a
great night I will see you again very
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you